cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com so this is Australia from
Yahoo Russell Brand uncovers Twisted BBC
conspiracy to collaborate on big stories
with other news outlets this is what I
was talking about right it's a funny
um misinterpretation of exactly what
Russell Brand is actually saying they
say in what seems like an awful lot of
the classic magicians trick where you
direct the audience attention one hand
so you don't see what's happening in the
other Russell Brand hopped on Rumble for
a new episode of his Daily Show Stay
Free and reveal that apparently
Independent News organizations are
secretly collaborating or conspiring to
control Global News narratives in some
of the most important stories in the
world gasp surely that is way worse than
anything else that may be going on right
now here's the point
the idea that news organizations were
colluding with each other on stories was
a scandal when it came out it was the
journal list yes it came out in like
2011. this is old news uh so the journal
list there's more than one yep uh
journalists at various organizations
were on a Facebook list with each other
where they were sharing all the stories
hence all the organizations
organizations would put up the same
stories around the same time that's a
scandal it is corruption what they're
now saying what they're now saying in
the presses oh can you believe it so
stupid that's totally normal they do
this yeah it's it's old news this is my
point is it's the cycle of first you're
crazy it's not happening yeah then even
if it was happening it's not even that
bad then it's it's a good thing it's a
good thing and now we're at the it's a
good thing that news organizations all
cool with each other to to control the
narrative I mean what's the fourth
estate even for right normally it was
for keeping the government honest for
expecting money for big Pharma yeah now
it's attacking private citizens like the
the NBC article they tweeted it out
right going oh Russell Brand attacks the
British government oh no not attacking
the brisket and the good yeah good I
hope it's gonna I hope it's got
something it's like oh we better rush in
to protect the British government
exactly all these private citizens of
monolith yeah exactly the private
systems criticizing the government um
you're an American company aren't you in
favor of that I mean we're supposed
let me ask you as a as an actual Brit
yep many people people have said you
know because I asked like who cares
about Russell Brand is and people are
saying that it's front page tabloid news
it's a huge deal in the UK yeah break it
down for us what it's like in the UK I
mean it was literally one on on one
particular day every single Paper
whether left-wing or right wing had
Russell Brand as a rapist but but but
why Russell is he really that big in the
UK no not really
the thing is
there are a lot of things here right so
Russell Brand is famous in the UK but
he's not on TV anymore right he hasn't
been on TV just reruns right no no not
even reruns because Russell Brand got
really famous in Britain probably about
20 years ago something like that doing a
show called Big Brother's big mouth
right he did he did a bunch of other
stuff but this was the one that I think
it's the most notable and the thing is
that's not the sort of thing you do
reruns on because it was a commentary on
Big Brother the TV show oh it was on so
you know you wouldn't really he was just
commenting on a reality show yeah yeah
yeah exactly right it was always meant
to do podcasting yeah yeah no he
probably was this was before podcasting
even existed exactly and uh and to be
honest with you right I don't really
like having to defend Russell Brand
because he is annoying right he
he was I don't know right because we
only had 40 four TV channels and
channels one three were really boring
right and so you're like 17 18 years old
you've got to watch channel four oh it's
Russell he's so annoying he was just
insufferable but I have to say he has
changed a lot you know he has matured
and actually I've been watching his
content recently actually it's quite
consumable right um and so and possibly
because I agree that he's right on the
general thrust of his message which is
of course anti-establishment like the
rest of us yeah um and so good I'm glad
that he's sort of come over to this side
and there's there's a distinct advantage
that he has his because in 2015 the left
was trying to say look we're going to
use Russell Brown to reach the youth you
know the youth the listening to him um
but actually not really so much the
youth and listen to him it's 40 year old
women who are listening right this is I
mean look at his matching his messaging
very feminine but he's got a particular
way with women and you can see it in his
hands and in his Cadence and in the way
he gives them his total focus and is
accessorizing right yeah yeah he dresses
it really is very he's fam accessorized
exactly right and so like but if you
think about it actually the way that the
left works
they use middle-aged white women as kind
of Stormtroopers they do absolutely they
they use them really really aggressively
the wine moms yeah that whole thing yeah
because they're deeply invested in a lot
of left-wing um presuppositions and
axioms and and these were the feminists
exactly they've committed their lives to
these things it's like look you know I'm
gonna grow old alone and I've had a
bunch of abortions and I've got triple
digit body count right and I have to
defend my lifestyle rather than thinking
guilt exactly if you nail me on all of
this then I realize that I've wasted my
life and I'm a terrible person and
Russell Brown speaks to a lot of this
sort of slice of the population and I
think really they're trying to poison
him against them and weirdly enough
there are loads of like 40 year old
women who are coming out and defending
Russell Brand because they've been a fan
of his for a long time they have
absolutely and so it's it's interesting
that he has been attacked in this in
this way now right it's now that is the
the issue but to be honest with you this
could have happened at any time because
Russell Brown did these things
why is why is a member of parliament
writing letters to various networks well
that's the point and that that really is
the big question isn't it because it you
realize that the left's control is
entirely predicated on a kind of magical
spell that they cast Over You yup it's a
kind of it's just words that's all
they've ever used and just the word no
would have stopped all of this all the
time right just the word no would have
would have stop them every hurdle but
they were of course like no oh you're a
racist you're a big and you're like God
no don't accuse me unreasonably no
I hope we're all past this right when
the left accuses you of anything it's
because they hate you and want to
destroy you that's the only reason I've
ever done it just laugh yeah exactly you
just go well whatever you know I think
you want to molest kids
like advertising a lot of like Rumble
exists on Advertising Revenue no it
doesn't doesn't it Rumble right now I
think for the most part existing is
existing on investment but why is Dan
bongino freaking out freaking out yeah
the longevity he's been pretty upset on
Twitter about like the attacks on Rumble
I think for guys I I think Rumble is
predicated a lot of the revenue is
likely coming from uh subscriptions when
people sign up for locals that's a big
component they're operating off a lot of
investment and how much was burking even
spending on Rumble with 44 million
unique day monthly visits nobody ever I
mean no I just think to scale to compete
with YouTube you do need the appetizer
Revenue so of course Dan bongino should
defend the company it'll be the
stupidest thing he came out said I don't
care about advertisers no he should be
like they're attacking us and they also
went after X they also went after
Twitter they grabbed like 60 of the
revenue I mean it does matter that these
activists are going to corporations and
our boycotts are working and it's that
the it's that the media companies rather
are going to these corporations
demanding that they retract their
advertising from certain sites and that
seems to be really egregious this
concept of the good corporate citizen
needs to go we don't need good corporate
citizens we need good corporations we
give Burger King the Bud Light treatment
yeah Burger King like we can't wait yeah
we keep boycotting things that I don't
buy anyway the problem as I understand
when when the apocalypse happen with
Pewdiepie
um I remember reading an article that
described how YouTube YouTube's
advertising model worked and it said
that there was something like six sort
of advertising conglomerates so a
company will go to this conglomerate and
say I want however much money spent on
YouTube and they'll be like right here
we'll get it sorted for you and so they
have like stables and advertisers and
one of these apparently threatened Paul
from YouTube and YouTube then collapsed
them back down on everything right
because it's never been a profitable
platform but but think about this and
this is true for for Elon and Elon is
doing exactly what I advocated for
during the first adpocalypse if
Coca-Cola
comes to YouTube and says look man we
got a bunch of angry emails about
PewDiePie saying naughty words if I was
YouTube I would be like we've apologized
for it we've told PewDiePie like hey man
you got to watch yourself you can't do
this he said it was an accident he's
very sorry but I appreciate you bringing
it up that's really great when can we
expect your renewal and then when Coke
says no if you don't Implement these
changes and do what we want we pull I
would respond with oh that's too bad
Pepsi just came to us with a billion
dollar offer for ads it'd be a shame if
there was no advertising for Coca-Cola
and it was just all Pepsi but you know
we can arrange that Pepsi and Coke both
send you an email then my response is so
uh it would be really unfortunate if the
largest Millennial and gen Z social
media platform had all of its creators
complaining all at once about how their
money disappeared and our responses were
so sorry it's Coke and Pepsi who made
the choice that to support you what do
you think is going to happen to the
younger generation when every single one
of their celebrity Heroes comes out and
says never buy this trash again you want
to go to war you will lose
the platforms but Elon Musk and Elon
Musk now understanding what YouTube
didn't decided to go to war and say we
will come after you oh where they're
suing right yeah and he says go by all
means Elon Knows X is the water cooler
and if they want to pull ads he laughs
and says we provide revenue streams to
some of the most influential political
commentators in the world what do you
think is going to happen when and I'll
I'll just me yo I post pictures of trump
stroking a chicken and I get 250 million
impressions per month that means my my
my stupid little post gets scrolled
through by people that many times Elon
knows this and he's smart and so he can
go to these advertisers and he can say
what do you think's gonna happen if you
pull your ads and this guy right here
he's a liberal he gets a billion views
and he's a fan of ours what do you
think's gonna happen when he tweets out
to all of his liberal fans that you guys
are betraying the spirit of what of what
we're working on it's going to whatever
you whatever money you think you're
going to lose by advertising on our
platform with with nasty speech you will
lose 100 fold for coming out against us
the thing is they'll make a moral
argument that will make it Justified and
Noble for them to lose whatever money
you threaten with them to lose right and
so they will come across as the big
Winners and then they've got the entire
media machine that will start saying oh
you know Noble heroic international
corporation it well they've already done
it I know you're saying there's a
Tipping Point basically it doesn't
matter because when you look at 30
billion dollars lost Bud Light and
Target are being sued right now by a
political shareholders who are like why
would you do this to my money and now
you've got you've got hedge funds and
and investment firms that are being like
this is a we just lost how much
percentage of our portfolio for all of
our clients and our clients are are
Furious right now we can't risk
investing sell sell sell
comes in Bill Gates and starts buying a
bunch of Bud Light
probably because he's like thinking he's
gonna buy a dip or he's like they need a
rescue they need their snipers turn
around but when it comes to this at a
certain point you must recognize that
you might not have the winning hand but
you have the winning play so I I haven't
made a poker reference in a long time so
I'm going to take the opportunity right
now yeah
you you go to a low stakes poker table
and No One Believes when I say this
if I if I get dealt trash cards
so second best hand in Texas Hold'em
pocket kings two kings in your hand I
have gotten people to fold the second
best hand simply because I bet one
hundred dollars and then they're like I
can't do it it doesn't matter if I have
an 80 chance to win I don't want to lose
a hundred dollars in one hand and they
will fold and then I'll flip over seven
deuce the worst garbage hand and I'll
say I know I'm going to lose but I can
put pressure on Elon Musk can look at
these farms and he can say I know we
don't have near the capital to go up
against all of you but I know you're
more scared of me than I am of you
here's a better example I remember when
I was driving I was a little kid my
dad's in a Jeep Wrangler Bare Bones
steel frame no bells and whistles and
some luxury sedan is trying to cut my
dad off and my dad laughs and he's like
yeah I'll call your bluff dude you're
not scratching your luxury sedan on my
hunk of junk rusted Jeep and my dad just
carried on ignoring him so this guy is
putting pressure on this guy with a
really nice car and my dad's laughing
like you think I care about this hunk of
junk is it so my point is this
Elon Musk might not have the best most
powerful play but is Coke willing to
take how much how much economic damage
are any of these advertisers willing to
sustain because elon's like it's my
existence
I have no choice if you want to lose
five percent fine so be it but if we do
nothing we cease to exist so we will put
all of our resources up against you and
you know what you might lose five
billion dollars is the 5 billion worth
it to you and they're gonna say
I don't want the headache man the left
operates off of creating a headache for
people yeah they call and they say
whatever so this is what happens because
conservatives Libertarians post-liberals
whatever are we are are so quick to just
back down and say please leave me alone
the left knows that applying any small
amount of pressure results in a victory
if we counter that and simply say
10 so so we were doing an event and they
started calling the venue and the venue
said screw off we've had we've had a
bunch of this happen recently my answer
is simply look guys we've worked with
you for x amount of time you make money
working with us you've gotten 30 emails
likely all came from the same person I
assure you if you cancel the economic
hit you will take will be worse than
ignoring 30 emails and you know what's
happened over the past several years
they say we get it we get it we're good
don't worry about it the the problem
with all this is this isn't happening in
isolation because if it was just these
things moving on the board then yeah
you'd be totally right but they have a
huge International apparatus that's
currently moving against our chess
pieces the international part is is key
too I mean look it's the British
government going after Russell that's
right you know it's States and Rumble
already told I think France yeah do they
already banned in France right but the
thing is then but then you get the
European Union because France a major
player in the European then they're
going to start moving against like alt
Tech as well and they're just going to
slowly grind us down because we don't
have BlackRock backing us you know we
don't have the media backing us we don't
have every celebrity backing us I don't
think that matters I I really think they
they operate off of complacency yeah
they do yeah and it is a fact that any
amount of pressure breaks the the mental
will of the average person who doesn't
want to be involved this is involved
this is what the left operates on yeah
so like I was saying earlier what I've
been hearing more and more over the past
few years first with 2018 into 2020.
I'm talking to people and they're saying
things like I want Trump to lose because
I am sick of hearing about him I want
the fighting to stop
Trump loses it didn't stop now these
people are saying they won't go away
bring Trump back so he can crush them
and finally make it stop what people are
starting to realize is the promises of
the media stopping what they're doing
and the the government stopping what
they're doing it was never about Trump
and so now the attitude is Trump's not
even President Biden's screwing up
across the board we've got war and
crisis and they're continuing the
pressure and the conflict why won't it
stop Trump says I'll make it stop and
now people are starting to say fine the
Normie doesn't want to be involved and
the left use that to their advantage to
get them to side with them but then
after they won they would not stop they
kept pushing and pushing and pushing
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time